thanks to the great courses plus for
helping support this episode
hey crazies i've been skeptical of
hawking radiation for a very long time
if nothing can escape a black hole how
could a black hole possibly radiate
anything
it's ridiculous but after reading the
scientific papers on the subject i'm
kind of on board with it now hawking
radiation has a lot more in common with
strings than particles
let's get into this
if you've heard of hawking radiation
before then you've probably heard the
following explanation
particle anti-particle pairs are popping
in and out of existence everywhere all
the time
if one of these pairs forms on the event
horizon of a black hole
one partner inside and one outside then
one can escape
and the other can't without being able
to recombine
they can't annihilate which means
they've popped into existence but can't
pop back out
the particle outside the event horizon
needs a lot of energy to escape
that energy must come from somewhere and
the only thing around is the black hole
if the black hole loses energy then it
loses mass which means it shrinks
until eventually it's gone except
this explanation leads to a lot of
questions
shouldn't the in-falling particle add to
the mass of the black hole
but then the pair of particles came from
nothing so was energy not conserved for
black holes
why does the outside particle even have
enough energy to escape
these are the questions that always came
to my mind it's why i always thought
hawking radiation was bogus
in fact i had every intention of this
video being a debunking extravaganza
but then i read several scientific
papers while researching
including hawking's original work the
title of which is solid youtube
clickbait
as it turns out black holes do radiate
away their mass
it's just that particles popping in and
out of existence is a bad explanation
this is not how hawking radiation works
good old hawking made up an incorrect
explanation because he thought it was
easier for the general public to swallow
but the real explanation makes a lot
more sense and doesn't raise so many
questions
as long as you understand two things
black holes
and quantum fields quickie review time
a black hole is what you get when you
cram a lot of mass into a very small
space
they're so black that we can only see
them when they have material falling in
or when light emitting stars are
orbiting them
getting that much mass into such a small
space is not
easy which is why these tend to only
form at the end of a large star's life
the outer edges of the star get blasted
away by the supernova but the core
collapses in on itself if there's enough
mass in that core
it'll collapse to form a black hole you
mean it'll collapse into a black hole
right no i mean what i said it'll
collapse to form one
the collapsing core material is not the
black hole
the event horizon that forms around it
is
black holes aren't material things
they're space-time itself
the event horizon isn't a solid surface
it's just a place we can't see beyond
it's a collection of points in space and
moments in time
that have been separated from the rest
of the universe
once an event horizon forms it doesn't
matter what happens to anything inside
it
black holes are like spherical blemishes
in space-time
black balls in space
they'll bend the paths of anything
inside that space-time
including light an accretion disc is
what happens to material
as it falls into a black hole this is
what it would look like if you try to
see it from different angles
if it can do that to light imagine what
it can do to a quantum field
okay this one is tough and it's
definitely something i learned more
recently
when i feel motivated i read through a
little more of this textbook
i've learned enough so far that i i
think i can explain what we need to know
for this video
here's the gist we like to imagine that
particles are little bits of matter
flying around through space
but in quantum field theory there's just
a field filling space with quantum
properties
each point has a little uncertainty but
they all hover around
zero for the most part a particle is
just what it looks like when one of
those points
isn't hovering around zero there's a
little concentration of energy there
as that energy moves around it looks
like a particle is moving around
that isn't the whole story though it
understates the weirdness that is a
quantum field
this field is filling space with quantum
properties
but what makes those properties quantum
is that they're probabilistic
every point in space is teeming with
everything that could possibly happen
there
we only see a particle somewhere when we
reduce those possibilities to one
the thing is though it's possible for
those non-particle points
to become particles
considering all the possibilities at
once in such an abstract way can be a
bit overwhelming
unless you're an observer from fringe so
we try to lean on visuals that we
already know
maybe you can try imagining all this
empty space isn't empty
but is filled with particles virtual
particles
that's where that popping in and out of
existence idea came from
it's complete nonsense though we call
them virtual
because they're not real but nonsense is
okay
if it's helpful for hawking radiation
virtual particles are the opposite of
helpful too many questions
we need better nonsense believe it or
not
hawking radiation has a lot more in
common with strings than particles
consider a string stretched between two
heavy blocks
if you pluck the string it'll vibrate
but some vibrational frequencies are
easier for the string than others
they're the string's natural frequencies
also known as normal modes
these are the ones where the wave loops
fit nicely on the string
there are an infinite number of them but
the first several examples are the most
dominant
one loop two loops three loops and so on
oh yeah real nice anyway
they're all available to the string
unless we pinch it
if you pinch the center of the string
that point must remain stationary
which eliminates some of the available
frequencies
you pinching the string changes what the
string can do
black holes do something similar for
quantum fields
now rather than having a flickering box
represent the point in space
we'll just take snapshots of it across
time
this pattern can be expressed by a
combination of positive and negative
wave modes
the positive modes go forward in time
and the negative modes go backward in
time
hopefully you can see now why a quantum
field is kind of like a wave on a string
usually nothing weird happens the
positive and negative modes tend to
cancel out
when someone says virtual particles this
is actually what they're talking about
the quantum wave activity of the vacuum
for contrast a real particle looks like
this
and a real anti-particle looks like this
what does this have to do with hawking
radiation it's all about that vacuum
activity
like i said these vacuum modes usually
cancel out
but not when there's a black hole the
formation of a black hole
kind of pinches the quantum field like
your fingers did with the string
remember how pinching the string made
some of the vibrational modes
unavailable
well the black hole does the same thing
with the waves in the quantum field
some of the modes before the black
hole's formation aren't available after
by making part of the quantum field
unavailable
the modes don't cancel anymore the black
hole has turned the vacuum
into a particle-filled region of space
the key word there being region
these new particles are not localized to
the event horizon
they're emerging from a large region of
space around the black hole
a region that's a few times larger than
the event horizon
and let me tell you it's a lot easier
for particles to escape from way out
here
than it is for them to escape from in
here they're going pretty fast though
right
oh yeah definitely fast fast hawking
radiation
is almost exclusively photons phlotoms
what's a phlotom
hawking radiation is almost exclusively
photons
otherwise known as light and that light
has a gigantic wavelength
it's upwards around 80 times the radius
of the black hole by the time it finally
escapes
that's not visible light that's extreme
radio waves
i'm serious when i say it isn't
localized these new particles can't just
come from nowhere though
all particles have energy and that
energy has to come from somewhere
conservation of energy shall not be
violated
and the only thing around is that black
hole
remember that a black hole is not a
physical object
it's pure unadulterated space-time
curvature
the energy for hawking radiation comes
from that curvature which means the
curvature will decrease
and according to einstein's equation
less curvature
means less mass a radiating black hole
will lose mass and shrink but unless
there are some micro black holes roaming
around
not a single black hole in the universe
has begun shrinking yet
they're emitting hawking radiation so
slowly
that what they're eating still makes
them grow even the isolated ones
are eating the cosmic microwave
background fast enough to grow
huh it's no wonder we haven't detected
it yet
in the unimaginable far future the
universe
will cool off enough to allow black
holes to shrink
it'll start slowly but speed up as it
shrinks
the energy of the radiation will grow
until eventually it's visible
in the black hole's final moments it'll
erupt violently
with massive particles not just photons
black hole explosions indeed mr hawking
when this eruption happens depends on
the black hole's size once it starts to
shrink
for stellar mass black holes it'll take
an octodecillion times the current age
of the universe
that's 10 to the 67 years for
supermassive black holes it could easily
take a million google years
the bigger it is the slower it
evaporates
no matter what though all black holes
will evaporate
eventually but not because particles are
popping in and out of existence at their
event horizons
just like pinching a string makes
vibrational modes unavailable
a black hole kind of pinches space-time
which makes
quantum modes unavailable doing so the
quantum vacuum doesn't cancel itself
anymore
and you get particles those particles
which are almost certainly photons
are called hawking radiation and that
radiation
carries energy away from the black hole
eventually
so much energy will get carried away
that the black hole completely
disappears
a black hole might be a blemish in space
time but it has a mechanism to correct
itself
which is kind of beautiful actually so
did this help you understand hawking
radiation a little better let us know in
the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to supporters
like brian webber who's pledging at the
asylum orderly level on patreon
thanks to all my patrons and youtube
members for making it possible for this
to be my job
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember
it's okay to be a little crazy thanks
again to the great courses plus for
helping support this episode
these days my videos are only about 10
to 15 minutes long which is
just long enough to teach you one aspect
of a topic
that's usually the key aspect that helps
you understand more elsewhere
maybe that elsewhere could be the great
courses plus
it's a subscription on-demand video
learning service
where you can enjoy lectures from top
professors from around the world
and experts from places like national
geographic the smithsonian and even the
culinary institute of america
with a subscription you get access to a
huge
library of over 11 000 video lectures
like the series black holes tides and
curved space-time
understanding gravity by dr benjamin
schumacher
there are a total of 24 half-hour
lectures in this series
with lots of historical context from
newton to einstein and hawking
if you're interested in that sort of
content they're offering my viewers a
free trial
go to thegreatcoursesplus.com science
asylum
or click the link in the description
below to get started
using the link lets them know i sent you
and that helps on the channel
hey what about mars and venus's orbit
the original draft of the venus video
did have that in there but the answer
was so boring that i cut it
basically nothing would change anyway
thanks for watching